hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about how to unwrinkle your wrinkles
okay so there's two concepts one is
fixing it from the outside and using
creams and lotions and rubbing in your
face and trying to get rid of wrinkles
the other concept is from the inside out
where you're eating certain things that
come from within and then come out and I
like this approach a lot better than
trying to use some external thing that
you're applying on the skin so most of
the anti-wrinkle creams use something
called retinol that is a synthetic
vitamin A ok so vitamin A is really
important with the skin especially for
acne scarring and just really beautiful
skin some of the dry skin problems that
you see out there are it's not that the
person is dehydrated it's that they're
missing certain healthy fats so if we go
over here and talk about what fats that
would be good that would provide by them
an a egg yolks are at the top the list
okay so you don't want to just have the
egg whites you want the hoax
especially butter grass-fed butter very
important cod liver oil virgin cod liver
oil would be a really good vitamin A and
vitamin D complex to help get those
essential nutrients these are fat
soluble nutrients
I would also consume the vitamin A in
vegetables but just realize when you do
that you're consuming a pre vitamin A
and they're called carotenoids so pre
vitamin A is carotenoids active vitamin
A is retinol however there's a lot of
benefits of consuming the pre vitamin A
complexes and additional phytonutrients
to help your skin protective factors
great for growing healthy skin and one
of the things like to do is mix these
two together I don't do a lot of spinach
because it tends to increase oxalates
and it can lead to stones but kale and
parsley are awesome to mix together
where you could blend those in a shake
put some blueberries fill it up with
water and consume that as your final
nutrients that would really help your
skin and I would recommend collagen
peptides as your raw material to build
healthy skin
I use a brand called Vita protein which
is grass-fed pasture raised from Brazil
high quality stuff now on the flip side
you also want to avoid things okay so
you're going to be consuming things and
avoiding certain things a couple things
that will really destroy your skin is
high levels of insulin so you have to
lower that if you have a pre-diabetic
situation or you're diabetic and you
have insulin resistance which most
people do you can't absorb this collagen
in the body you can't absorb vitamin A
so that is a problem especially with
aging skin so just by fixing this alone
your skin will really be youthful and
the way to do it is by cutting up the
sugar do the keto and especially the
intermittent fasting and you've been
watching my videos you know why because
in termina fasting will stimulate
something called a tapa g which is a
recycling effect of yourself clearing
out the old damaged parts renewing the
cells renewing the skin just that alone
will give you a really nice layer of
skin okay so you want an intimate
fasting cut the sugar out do keto and
also reduce cortisol cortisol is a
stress hormone it destroys the skin it
turns the protein in the skin into sugar
and it gives you a lot of sagging skin
and collagen so of course to do that
you're going to get enough sleep do long
walks and try to reduce the stress as
much as possible the last factor is this
thing called bile bile the stuff in your
gallbladder it's the material that helps
dissolve the grease and the fats that
you eat it's the material that helps
extract vitamin A and vitamin E and the
other fat side of atamans from the fat
that you eat and if you don't have
enough bile consuming vitamin A products
just won't work so how do you know if
you have enough bile well here's some
things if you don't have a gallbladder
you're gonna need some more biome if you
have a congested gallbladder let's say
you're bloated all the time you're gonna
need some help with the bow if you have
a fatty liver chances are you probably
don't have enough bile some of the
symptoms that would indicate low bile
would be burping belching bloating right
shoulder pain pain in the upper trap
here those are all symptoms
gall bladder in liver so one of things I
recommend for that situation would be
gall bladder formula it doesn't just
have purified bile salts it has enzymes
for the pancreas it has enzymes for the
stomach it helps the bile be thinned and
it helps you extract these fat soluble
vitamins from your food and into the
skin all right thanks for watching hey
before you go definitely sign up for my
free keto course I put a link down below
it's on messenger in Facebook but it
will give you all the basics it's very
quick it's like three or four videos and
it's free check it out